- Thank You, Economy
is my last audio book.
- [DRock] When was that?
- 2011, probably recorded it in
December 2010.
(whooshing)
(thumping)
(upbeat music)
- I really don't have a
mindset on social media.
I do things, I look at things from
this lens that
I'm doing something fun and cool
and I find it interesting,
and I want to share it, I share it.
I'm usually of the nature of
being more private than anything,
but seriously.
(laughing)
Some people, and obviously
it's going to be you,
I've always been told
people just want to see
just the dumbest things that you're doing.
You may not find it interesting,
but everybody else finds it interesting
just because it's a lens
into your world, and whatnot.
So, I'm getting a little bit
more comfortable with that.
- And just so you know,
just so I keep aligning things,
and I'll get more detailed
about this in '16,
I don't not believe in anything.
Thank you so much.
- [DRock] You're welcome.
Have a good day.
- [Gary] You too.
(pulsing music)
- [Gary] Yes sir.
Ready to star in some DailyVee action?
- Oh, boy.
(laughing)
- He's funny to edit
because I have to wa--
I mean, I never watch anything
of my own stuff ever before,
but I have to watch this.
There's just so much.
- [Jason] Right, and I
can see you sitting down.
- It was like that part--
Like, literally, I got to
that point and I was like,
I'm going to leave that in there,
because I think Jason's going to watch it.
(laughing)
I'm hoping he's going to be like,
what did he say?
Because, for me it was easy.
I was going up against something
where I would market,
and then I would see it come through
the dot com shopping cart,
or my register in the store.
So, I never had to debate
the things that you have to debate.
The big shock to me
when I came into corporate America
was reporting.
Millward Brown,
Neilson's brand list.
Even the stuff that's been
beneficial to our business,
DataLogics.
Just reporting.
(hip hop music)
You know, for me,
when I do business meetings,
it's kind of interesting,
I just so know where my
intent and my skills are,
that I actually--not judge,
but I size up the other side
based on how they react to me.
Because if it goes well,
it means they're seeing what I'm saying,
there's a belief on the--
there's an alignment on the religion.
You've got to back it up now.
But I want to put myself on the hook,
and I'm always so thankful
when very senior people
are not posturing to the history,
they're open-minded,
they're bringing their strong
points of view as well.
But it's like a fair debate,
it's honest, it lacks emotion,
it's just business,
and it's just a great
way to get the day going.
To have an invigorating, high-level,
important meeting.
That was fair.
And, by the way,
if I don't get any business
or if my business doesn't grow,
and I felt that was fair,
and that's happened in the past,
because I don't think what I do
or what we do aligns with them,
I also feel good.
It's not about the win,
it's about the fairness.
Meritocracy, baby.
Even at your own expense,
something that a lot of
people haven't learned yet.
♫ Harm anybody who ridin' against
♫ She said you done had a long day, baby
♫ Let me get up on top
♫ She know I'm a winner, yeah
♫ She know I'm a winner
♫ I'm'a figure how to get up on top
♫ Okay, okay
♫ I'm a Ponce de León
♫ What you want ♫
- That's fine, or, or, or
maybe I could see her over the weekend
if she wants to stop by and see the kids.
Because she's a family friend
with Dave, so ask, okay?
Okay, okay, bye.
(muttering)
- [Rick] Hi there, Gary.
- Gary.
The nice thing is, I'm excited is that,
the questions are already read
so it's going to be interesting to see.
- [Rick] We'll put you on headphones.
You'll hear the questions,
we'll be able to play
the questions for you.
- It's huge, and you know what's crazy?
I have a crazy idea.
You know what's interesting?
You want to talk about
why the audio book?
(grunting)
Okay, cool, I'm excited.
I think this is going
to go really well, yeah.
What's better than uh,
you know what's actually really rad?
How did I answer to the book,
and how did I answer in the audio book?
Like what little, subtle things changed
in a three or four month period?
I mean, if I could just sit
and just answer questions
I'd be done in four seconds.
- [Rick] Come on in.
Cozy, worth it.
Few studios in New York City
that has a window.
(laughing)
So you can be there
with a little human light in this place.
Which is, so always good.
- Let me take a second
and catch up on my life,
give me a second.
- [Rick] Getting the iPad.
- [DRock] What is the last audio book?
Thank You, Ecocomy, right?
- Thank You Economy
is my last audio book.
- [DRock] When was that?
- 2011.
I think it came out on March '11,
so I probably recorded
it in December 2010.
(chuckling)
So that's one thing that changed
since five years ago,
when I did my last book.
- No more paper.
I don't know if you're going to need this,
you may not want it,
but that's a list of the questions
and who's asking them,
and the order in which they come up.
- This is so cool how he did it.
- You'll want this page,
so that people will say
all sorts of things.
- Like this, like literally
everything that's on the page?
- Yeah, well, not all of them.
- Got it.
(chuckling)
- Maybe you'll leave an open question.
But--
(muttering)
A little later there's
a Missy Elliot lyric.
You can't sing.
- I won't.
- That's not an evaluation.
(laughing)
- People are actually reading questions
and I'm answering them in the book.
- Alright, so we're anticipating
some improvisation here, yes?
But let's try reading,
obviously you want to read the credits.
- I'm going to read, yeah,
there's an opening setups we will read,
and then when I was reading it myself,
it was funny how I was,
there was something interesting going on,
which is, I improv'd
eight to 13 percent in my first two books.
Here, I could see going a lot more.
Okay, this is now from
a business standpoint,
there is an absolute scenario here
where a lot of people could end up
buying both the book and the audio book
if I make them aware that I basically--
- That there's a difference.
There's more value.
- Some of these answers
I gave a year and--
By the way, some of them I saw
and things changed even when
I couldn't change them anymore.
- Like Andy Dalton.
(laughing)
- [Gary] Very good.
- You've got a lot of material to do,
we've got a lot to do,
there's only one cardinal rule.
Don't rush.
You've got to listen to the audio
that was up on Audible for the last book.
Sounded perfect.
The pace was great, you weren't rushing,
the big temptation is to push too fast.
Pull back, relax.
- I feel very good about the
time that we've allocated.
I think, in general, you'll
see that I'll probably
start a little bit too hard,
because I'm excited, but cool.
- [Rick] Gary, can you hear me?
- I can hear you perfectly.
- [Rick] Great, thank you.
The wonderful moments.
Alright, so what I ask for getting levels
and things of that sort.
To the Vayniacs, it's the first,
it's the dedication if you will.
- Before we do the--
- [Rick] Just because that's not going
to give us enough say.
So, let me hear you read that,
and we'll get a level, go.
- To the Vayniacs and the Vayner Nation,
and all the people who have watched
even one video over the last ten years,
your attention is my oxygen.
Harper Audio presents
#AskGaryVee, One Entrepreneur's Take
on Leadership, Social
Media, and Self-Awareness,
by Gary Vaynerchuk.
Sometimes you get emotional
at some of these things.
Do I say the word acknowledgements?
- [Rick] Yeah.
- Acknowledgements.
Nothing I do is possible without
the support of my family.
My heart belongs to my wife Lizzie,
and my kids Misha and Xander.
At the time I really did think I was done
with daily video blogging forever.
I could imagine the occasional interview
or one-off video.
Have you seen my Monday morning
motivational spot?
But a full show was too much.
There was only one
thing I didn't count on,
you, the Vayner Nation.
I missed you.
Meanwhile, the e-mails kept pouring in.
Despite access to three
books and hundreds of videos,
people still had questions;
How to successfully use social media,
the new platforms, and the old standbys?
To build their brands,
or how to market with native content,
or even just how do I do what I do?
There was so much content, I would--
There was so much content I
wanted to put out to help them,
but with all my other obligations
at VaynerMedia and elsewhere,
I just couldn't get to it.
And that's how on July 31st 2014,
on a YouTube channel
with 30,000 subscribers,
one of the world's first business
Q and A video blogs was launched.
It opened with a guy in
a blue-striped golf shirt
smiling into the camera.
Hello, everybody and--
Oh, I forgot my own intro.
(laughing)
Hello everyone,
and welcome to the first #AskGaryVee.
Though the first episode started off
almost as low-key as its
wine themed predecessors,
by the second the light
and the sound quality
were professional grade,
and the host was bringing hard energy
and straight thunder.
At first I thought the show might be an
every now and then thing,
but it was like riding a bike.
As soon as I filmed the first episode
I wanted to do more.
And just as I could never run
out of new wines to taste,
there will never be a day where there's
nothing new to say about
the state of business.
It's consistently evolving and growing.
- It's a constantly.
- [Gary] It's a constantly
evolving and growing topic.
- One more, it's a constantly.
- [Gary] It's a constantly
evolving and growing topic.
- Good man.
- By the way, you're doing
a great job, thank you.
It's helping me a lot.
Give me one second.
Even though I wanted to
get through that five,
I just need a second.
- Okay, we're about 10, 15 percent behind.
- Understood.
- A little bit behind.
Although I think we've found a rhythm.
- I'm sorry to break it up,
but I'll be as fast as I can.
Is there a bathroom out here?
- [Rick] Yes, there is.
(peaceful music)
- You're looking to
jumpstart the conversation
in a more healthy direction.
Chapter one, clouds and dirt.
I have a really, really good idea.
- [Rick] I'm listening.
- And then I'm going to really
take your advice on this.
I'm going to read this answer,
and then I'm going to listen to it,
and then I'm going to answer it.
I have a feeling that we're going to get
a much better audio book,
and go much faster,
but not faster like speed,
it's going to come much
more natural to me.
- With the second way of
doing it, right, okay.
I think that's going to work
and I think it's going
to work consistently
the shorter the answer.
If you've got a four paragraph answer,
it's going to be harder for
you to sort of recap it all,
ad libbed, I'm guessing.
I could be wrong.
- Interesting, let's find out.
- [Voiceover] How long is too long for
a fiscally responsible entrepreneur
to stay in a safe, full time job?
At what point do you have to accept
that it's not going to happen?
Is it ever too late to start?
- This question on the
show created a firestorm
after I answered what
I still believe today,
so, with all due respect to
all your collective feedback,
I'm going to go there again.
If you work in a job, you
are not an entrepreneur.
Now, I know that hurts,
and I'm going to say it again.
If you, right now,
as you're running through the airport,
or driving on the highway,
are going to a job,
you, my friend, are not an entrepreneur.
You may have entrepreneurial tendencies,
but you are not an entrepreneur.
Now, let me take a step back,
deploy a little humility in the bravado
that I'm about to spit.
Being an entrepreneur,
a purebred entrepreneur the way
that I see it, this is
one man's point of view,
this is the #AskGaryVee book, after all,
is somebody who doesn't even have
the ability to have ever had a job.
The reason I was an F student,
and I would like to
think most of you realize
at this point, I'm no dope.
I'm not a dummy.
It was because I couldn't deploy
going through that machine,
which was built to go get a job,
and I wasn't honing the skills
that I knew I had to have
to be who I was, and I knew
this at nine years old,
at 12 years old, at 15 years old,
at my junior year of high school,
I'm sitting in science class
reading the Wine Spectator.
I'm doing that because I'm
prepping to be a wine merchant,
because I was an entrepreneur.
There was nothing else.
If my dad didn't have a liquor store,
I would've built on the fact that I was
making $3,000 a weekend
selling baseball cards in the malls
of New Jersey as a 15 year old.
You don't think I could've
lived on 36,000 a year?
From working 52 days a
year, I sure could have.
And so that's who I was,
there was nothing else.
Now, a lot of you said
this is unfair of me,
this, that, and the other thing.
What I want you to know is,
my definition of an entrepreneur
should not be yours.
You want to think you're an entrepreneur
because you do what I said in Crush It!,
and come home from seven PM
to two in the morning
and built a business?
You want to tell me about
the fact that you have student loans
and you have to pay them off,
and that's why you have
to do it, I get it.
But I would flip it on you.
I think an entrepreneur
works under entrepreneurship,
and then works at 7-11 from 11 PM at night
to six in the morning
on the graveyard shift
if they have to be practical.
Because you have to understand
there is nothing else,
it's like telling a singer
that they can't sing, they
have to sing at night.
There is nothing else, you're drawn to it,
you can't breathe.
It is your absolute oxygen,
you are an entrepreneur when you are
building your business at all times.
And let me say another thing,
this is not 1992 anymore.
It is actually way more practical
to be an entrepreneur than
it's ever been before.
If you are 22 years old,
if you are not willing
to sleep on the floor
with nine of your buddies
in a studio apartment,
then you are not an entrepreneur.
If you want to get a job because
you want a watch or you want a car,
or you want to be able to take
out girls for a nice dinner,
then you are not an entrepreneur.
An entrepreneur does entrepreneur things,
and that is by definition
building a business
for yourself, period, end of story.
- [Rick] Cool, cool.
- The notes helped me
quite a bit on that one.
I'm taking the notes a
little more seriously,
I think it's going to be really impactful.
- It's fine, every system is different.
Whatever works.
(hip hop music)
- If you want to say skill,
because I've been honing
them for 32 of my 40 years,
then you can say skill.
That was kind of cool.
- [Rick] That was cool.
That was a good one.
Okay, how long is too long--
- Bob, man, this notes
thing is crushing it.
About ten more minutes,
the first 15 questions that come in
via Snapchat right now, I will answer.
Just had dinner with my folks,
and Lizzie and Misha.
Now about to start another meeting,
got to go back across the
street in a little bit.
Reading made me tired.
(hip hop music)